[Music]
foreign
a few weeks ago Vice held a panel
discussion with young Asian Americans
and here's how they describe the point
and theme of the conversation
what does it mean to be Asian in America
from hate crimes to the model minority
myth to affirmative action a politically
divisive panel hashes out the most
controversial issues facing the aapi
community today
now this is the kind of discussion
especially with hosted by an outlet like
Vice that is nearly certain to be
excruciatingly boring and Annoying It's
already guaranteed that the panel will
be stacked with leftists and leftists
are ideologically required to never say
anything remotely interesting especially
when the subject has anything to do with
race or ethnicity
but fortunately for the viewers there
was at least one young man who managed
to make it onto the panel despite having
a mind of his own a Twitter user named
Calum posted a couple of videos
featuring this man Vince is his name and
his contributions to the conversation
are quite interesting the clips are
revealing and instructive and also kind
of hilarious not because of what Vince
says I mean what he says is is good and
is correct
uh but there's nothing hilarious about
saying something that's true what makes
it funny is because of how the other
people on the panel react to him saying
those things so watch this
assimilation is it a good thing is it a
bad thing is is it a burden is it an
opportunity I think assimilation is not
just a great thing it's a necessary
thing no Society can hold together where
people have nothing in common they don't
speak the same language they don't
practice the same things and you know
you may look at something like just food
habits or what you eat and think that's
fairly frivolous but the truth of the
matter is that on a broader level when
we're talking about more big picture
things differences in race culture
religion all these things people have
fought Wars violent Wars killed each
other over these things for thousands of
years if America is to hold together
assimilation not just good or bad
necessary I don't think it's going to be
possible for America to survive as a
stable functioning Society if people
don't to some degree say well here's
what we're going to commonly agree upon
but who gets to choose it the majority
culture I suppose and what's the
majority culture people with power and
who's people with power people with
power white people well I don't I don't
know
it's okay I don't know if that's
necessarily so true I mean when can you
um yeah I don't let's collaborate I
don't think a particularly white
quote-unquote interest controls things
like in America culture do you believe
white supremacy exists I think there are
people who believe in and I think
there's people who all believe that
their race is superior so you don't
believe in white supremacy do you
believe America is a white supremacist
State no not at all interesting and not
found no white supremacist state would
even like allow us to be doing this like
I don't understand so white supremacist
this is KKK people walking actually I go
around New York City I notice that like
I guess Brooklyn a little bit different
most of the people here are not white
and they're doing their thing so I don't
know what does doing their thing mean to
you going to work are they making words
are they making the same amount of money
I gotta say I like this Vince guy I mean
I like it for all the reasons that
everyone else on the panel is shocked
and horrified by him first of all his
point about assimilation is obviously
correct a nation must be bound together
United by more than just the simple fact
that all of its people exist inside the
same geographical boundary that's even
more the case today when the
geographical boundary is so porous and
apparently according to this
Administration negotiable
we have so we have to have something
else holding us together
to be a people not just people but to be
a people we must have a shared culture
shared values share traditions a shared
language without those things you end up
with a fracturing and division that
leads to violence and that leads to
chaos and dysfunction
all of which we're experiencing today
of course everyone else in the room is
offended by this notion mostly because
they're conditioned to be offended by it
these are automatons operating based on
their programming it's also why the
obnoxious girl in the front row has
purple hair you know she can't help but
become a parody of herself it's like why
do these these obnoxious liberal women
why do why even do the purple hair
anymore you you're you're because you
are willingly making yourself into a
stereotype into one of the most mocked
stereotypes in existence right now you
are saying I'm going to be that person
but it's all programming
and she is aghast that Vince would
suggest assimilating with the majority
culture because she claims the majority
culture is white
and she sees white as automatically bad
and she holds this view even while
telling herself that she is not the
racist one
she along with her along with her
leftist cohorts are also scandalized
that Vince will not label America a
white supremacist state but as he points
out if America was run by violent white
supremacists who control everything
the first thing they'd probably do is
stop you from pointing this out
okay
like this is a pretty good indication so
if you want to know do do I live in a in
a white supremacist violent State well
can you stand anywhere can you go
anywhere and just say this is a violent
white supremacist State and nothing
happens to you
oh no no sorry that's not nothing
happens to you you can go anywhere and
say that and you'll be applauded
well that's the case then you don't live
in a white supremacist state
because non-white people can say and do
whatever they want and they can condemn
white people all they want without any
repercussions whatsoever unless as
repercussions you count again Applause
it's not exactly what you'd expect a
white supremacist dystopia to operate
that's not how you expect it to operate
like if you didn't know anything about
this country if you did you're crawling
out of a cave and someone told you
oh you know uh I got some bad news for
you you know you crawled out of a cave
into a white supremacist State you you
just so you know you live in a in a
systemically racist white supremacist
State when you hear that
and you don't know anything immediately
your mind is going to conjure all kinds
of images and you're going to make all
kinds of assumptions about what sort of
country this is and then you're going to
get out into the world and you're going
to find that wow it's not anything like
that at all in fact wow there's like
there's there's non-white people all
over the place running around talking
about how much they hate white people
and then there are other groups of
people there are white people following
behind them applauding
well that's not the kind of white
supremacist State I was expecting
so I do have to admit the guy at the end
was on to something he asked whether
non-whites make the same amount of money
as whites and the answer is no they
don't that's true
um because most of the people in that
room in fact belong to ethnicities that
make more more money than white people
on average
many Asian immigrants come to this
country and quickly find themselves in a
higher income bracket than the average
white family the median household income
for Asians in general is a hundred
thousand dollars for white households
it's 77 thousand dollars
this remains perhaps the most
Inconvenient Truth of all inconvenient
truths for the race Hustlers because if
America is a systemically racist country
systemically racist against non-whites
how could it possibly be the case that
many non-white communities fare better
than whites
in fact Vince always on the ball makes
this very Point later in the discussion
listen
statistically it is true that Asians
right on average make more money like in
terms of medium make more money better
test scores get into better colleges all
that stuff I think the question is why
is that and I don't know if model
minority whatever that label wants
that's actually a myth because we cannot
be um well no listen well let me finish
my point we need to observe what makes
people successful and unsuccessful and I
think when you look at trends that are
generally true in the Asian Community
not of everyone but are generally true
usually you have families that are
sticking together you have
um you know people are taught to work
hard in school not get into trouble I
think that translates to why Asians on
mass are successful and I don't think
you have to be Asian or white for that
matter to not have kids out of wedlock
not you know commit crime not not cause
trouble or whatever it is it's just a
matter of like well common sense that's
what makes people successful and if
that's so-called assimilation having a
nuclear family buying a house going to
school whatever it is then yeah okay
call me a pro assembly then I think
there's a difference between
assimilation and Erasure yes
now needless to say Vince is once again
completely and irrefutably right Asian
Americans do very well in this country
they also tend to have intact families
this is not a coincidence in fact if you
look at a ranking of median household
income by race
and then you look at a ranking of
divorce rate by race and out of wedlock
Birth by raise the lists are identical
okay the groups that are less likely to
get divorced less likely to have out of
wedlock births are also less likely to
be poor as the rates of broken homes
increase the rates of poverty increase
between whites blacks Hispanics and
Asians
the black community is the poorest it's
also the community with the most out of
wedlock births and broken homes the
statistics here again are irrefutable
the only crime that Vince committed was
noticing it
and as we've seen time and time again
one of the great moral crimes in our
culture today one of the only moral
crimes is the crime of noticing
like we all know that black people as a
group generally fare The Worst by every
societal measure pretty much we also
know that as a group they have the
highest rates of single-parent
households and kids raised with without
stable and reliable Parental Guidance we
all know all of that but but these are
facts we're supposed to keep on the
peripheral you're not allowed to turn
your head slightly to the side and look
directly at them
and if you do look at them you certainly
are not permitted to draw any
connections or form any conclusions and
if you do look at the facts and you form
conclusions they certainly better not be
conclusions that would even to the
slightest extent put the onus on the
black community to improve its own
situation okay you better not be
implying or suggesting or God forbid
outright saying that the black community
can do certain things itself to improve
its own position like for example have
kids get get married before you have
kids and then stay married like you're
not allowed to ever say that though I
just did
that's the greatest heresy of all
of course the other people in the room
reacted as you would expect those in a
religious cult to react to heresy if
you're only listening to the audio
you're not going to be able to fully
appreciate the scene because as Vince
calmly explains the benefits of having
intact families and discipline and you
know and encouraging education the other
panelists were they were left
slack-jawed you know they they stared in
horror their mouths a gape they shook
their heads they could not believe what
they were hearing they were in close
proximity with common sense perhaps for
the first time in their lives and they
found that the experience was was
terrifying
that to me is always is the most
disturbing thing yes obviously Vince is
right about everything he said obviously
the other panelists are wrong but it's
not just that they're wrong okay you can
be wrong about stuff it's just that they
they it's it's not just that they they
don't agree with Vince's Common Sense
data-backed analysis of the situation
it's really that they it's it's that
they were shocked by the analysis okay
it's one thing to be wrong to
misinterpret it to misread it but you're
shocked by it
it's that they apparently had never
heard anything like it before
it's one thing to disagree with an
obvious truth it's another to be stunned
by it
and that speaks to the suffocating
stifling bubble that these people have
been living in they clearly believe uh
what they believe merely because it's
the only belief that was ever presented
to them and they lack the intellectual
curiosity to survey the other options
they have nearly totally insulated
themselves from everything that might
challenge their worldview so when it
does happen
and they finally and by accident
encounter such a challenge they
practically faint like damsels in
distress
and that's what we saw there
and it's why Vince is not canceled today
in fact I just found out as I Was
preparing the segment that Vince has his
own YouTube channel which you can find
if you search Vince Dow d-a-o on YouTube
and you should look up he's obviously a
brilliant guy uh the same cannot be said
for the others in the room and that is
why they are today canceled that'll do
it for the show today as we move over to
the members block you become a member
and use code walls to check out for two
months free on all annual plans hope to
see you there if not talk to you on
Monday Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]